welcome to led live you know this time
of year you might hear a lot of
greetings like
merry christmas merry xmas or happy
holidays
but is christmas something that
christians should celebrate
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness you're watching
led live the show where we use the light
of christ to expose the darkness found
in media
and our culture today and today we are
going to jump right into this highly
requested topic of
explaining the origins of christmas
yeah it seems like no matter what our
video is lately it's like
talk about christmas so right that
you're doing this
yeah so let's let's talk about holidays
in general right throughout history
whether secular or religious every
single holiday seems to pay
homage to a person or a thing or an
event right like name a holiday even
today
easter easter okay what's that paying
homage to or like the event
bunnies
yes yes okay but what's the more common
jesus resurrection
right any any other holidays come to
mind thanksgiving
thanksgiving valentine's day
controversial one right there
remember we learned valentine's day was
actually something really bad wasn't it
yeah yeah that's right um so check out
that led live
video but christmas is no different the
question is
who is being publicly honored who is
being who's
who are we paying our homage to during
christmas
so i have a couple of questions here
where you answer just yes or no we're
gonna answer all together at the same
time after three
okay just yes or no
so first question is christmas a
christian
holiday one two three yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
i i think it's more yeah it's
complicated it's complicated okay
well here's the next question has
christmas always been
a christian holiday one two three
no that's okay that was unanimous nice
to explain that a little bit um
let's just say that early christians had
a soft spot for
for pagans unfortunately so instead of
following
james 1 27 and keeping themselves
unspotted from the world
they were oppressive but they were also
drawn to
these worldly practices as well so that
led them to taking in secular things and
making them their own
by adding a biblical spin or twist to it
and whether that's right or wrong i'll
leave that to the viewers discretion
but i'll give you the cliff notes as to
the history of christmas
going back to the third century romans
worshiped tammuz have you guys heard of
that god
tammuz well he's a babylonian son deity
and here's an excerpt from the book the
two babylons by alexander hislop you've
heard of that book before highly
recommend that book
december 25 was the date of the roman
pagan festival inaugurated in 274
as the birthday of the unconquered sun
which at the winter
solstice begins again to show an
increase in light and that still happens
today we have less sun during the winter
and more sun during the summer
well sometime before 3 36 the roman the
church in rome
unable to stamp out this pagan festival
spiritualized it
as get ready for this name the festival
of the nativity of the son of
righteousness that's our mouthful
that's interesting that's interesting
that we have the nativity
and during that time i'm sure you'll
bring that up and this son is
s-u-n right righteous
that christmas was originally a pagan
festival is beyond
all doubt the time of year and the
ceremonies
with which it is still celebrated prove
its origin
it's just interesting to me that almost
with everything that god does
the devil just has a counterfeit that's
right it's like he he he
takes those concepts and if he can shift
the focus a tiny bit
it's like i i think we've used this
illustration on our show before
um you know to turn somebody if you're
going towards a path like this
if you turn them ever so slight where
they don't notice that there's just a
little bit of
degree turned away over the course of
time those two lines will get further
and further apart
and so i think that's why you see a lot
of times error runs
so close in the same line as the truth
and it's
it's just to shift the focus yeah and
that's the power behind deception
that's right that means that the person
cannot tell the difference yeah unless
they're
really really focused on the word of god
and being directed by the holy spirit
yeah see if it was
if it was just some random i mean
i don't know how you get kind of bunnies
close to
uh the resurrection of christ but you
know if you think about
the the fertility or whatever at the
easter time um
and then christ being reborn and or
being raised again you know you can
kind of see how that would be sort of
but this is obviously
a very close you know thing to what
what the christianity christianities
so let's flesh out that last sentence
the time of
year the time of the year and the
ceremonies with which it is celebrated
prove its origin talking about christmas
so that's date
and activity keep those two things in
mind so question
when was jesus born we don't know i
don't know
like in april yeah in april i thought it
was in the fall
are you saying that because your
birthday's in april no november
i thought it was in the fall and i think
you can kind of know that
if you actually went and studied the
when the decree was that people had to
come back to
bethlehem um because i think there's
records of when they made that decree
and you had to travel and go register
and
and you could probably learn it but i
don't think i remember the actual
month that that i think that you can
also figure out when it is because
of when shepherds were out attending
their flock or something like that
that's right
yeah that's true so we can speculate and
we can
guess but we really don't know for sure
exactly the bible gives clues but it
doesn't
specifically say when it is do you think
that was because of the wisdom of god
like like not giving some of those
details so it didn't just
you know become a major thing for people
even though
you know it's you know we now celebrate
the birth but i don't think through the
history of the world
you know back in the in thousands of
years ago did they ever celebrate
their birth his birth is that kind of a
modern thing
so actually when i read the bible
there are only two birthday celebrations
and they didn't end up good for
christians
and that's actually the reason why
jehovah's witness don't celebrate
birthdays
is because of those two stories okay wow
well scholars haven't come to a
unanimous decision as to when
or what time jesus was born but based
off of the clues like the shepherds and
and the the climate of bethlehem
they speculate jesus was born in the
spring
or the summer or the fall but definitely
definitely not the middle of winter
everyone is clear on that
so when she was giving birth in a barn
it wasn't like she was freezing
exactly so to reiterate what we read
earlier
the date december 25th was chosen by the
catholic church
to establish the birthday of the savior
to coincide with the heathen feast day
to tammuz in an effort to eradicate the
pagan practices
of the time we'll just take it under our
label and
rebrand it but how do you eradicate
something
by adopting it i think that's why you
know when the bible speaks about
babylon and you know you just read this
thing that was talking about babylon
right there's a spiritual confusion
there
and and why babylon was was
we we equate babylon to spiritual
confusion is because when they would
soak up all the cultures around them
they wouldn't just do away with it they
would actually take it on as part of
their own so it was just this mixture of
things that were could be confusing and
and so i
i think it's a very ironic that you know
with the quote you just read right so uh
let me share a fun fact okay about the
united states
in regards to christmas so early america
actually had
no regard for christmas whatsoever and i
encourage you to do some research on
that because
the the controversy that's happening
with the puritans is actually pretty
hilarious
but congress sat in session on december
25 1789. they were working it wasn't
a day off yet that was actually
the country's first christmas under the
new constitution
christmas wasn't declared a federal
holiday until almost a century later
june 26 1870.
fairly recent yeah wow so now let's move
on to the second part we've talked about
the date
but what about the activities what
activities are done
on christmas and if you guys uh saw our
reaction video to the jubilee youtube
channel
about satanism remember keith made a
comment he's like isn't it ironic
that the same holidays that we celebrate
in honor of jesus
we also indulge in eating things that he
would never eat right like ham
you know because that's labeled unclean
in the bible i thought that was a little
ironic
but people take the opportunity to
overeat over drink
overspend on gifts it's like peak time
for consumerism
all right who's guilty yeah when you
have kids
it's very easy to do that even like when
i was a non-believer of
christianity or any of that i hated
holidays i was just like man this is
just some government scheme to make
people spend money it's like an
obligation i was like if i want to give
somebody something
i'll do it at in some you know unplanned
time
not like oh it's this date i must give
them a gift or i'm going to feel guilty
like
i always hated it you know i hated the
whole concept of it but
when you have kids it seems more like
you want to
i don't know it's unfortunate that the
gift giving has been
you know kind of flipped into so much of
of like what you
want you know what i mean rather than
what you can give
because if you really think about the
birth of christ i mean that is god
giving
the best of heaven to us and see the
devil just takes that and goes okay how
can i make this little system
you know turn it on its head so that
instead of us
just thinking about how can we give to
others it then
becomes this this selfish thing well i
wish i had this or i want this and
you know you're making this list of
everything that you want not what
what you would give to somebody else you
know what i mean
and and but i think that uh there has
been
um you know a great opportunity
presented
to actually give something to other
people during this time of the year
and i think that people are open and are
accepting of
of you know more spiritual
concepts you know during this time of
the year their people are kinder and all
this
um well actually the bible does tell us
the type of things that
god wants us to do to help others
when we look at matthew 25 verses 35 and
he he's the king in that parable is
telling
those who are rejected those who are not
welcome into the kingdom
i was hungry you didn't give me anything
to eat i was
thirsty you gave me no drink i was a
stranger you didn't take me in
i was naked you didn't clothe me i was
sick you didn't visit me i was in prison
you didn't come
on to me so those are things right there
that
we can do to help those who are less
fortunate
and we also have in isaiah
in isaiah chapter 58 the whole
long list although it talks about the
fast when you know the jews used to fast
with their long faces and their clothes
and
in sackcloth and ashes what what god was
saying
is that's not the fast that i have
chosen i am not interested
in you depriving yourself what i want
you to do
is to loose the bands of wickedness and
take away the heavy burdens from the
oppressed break every yoke
give bread to the hungry help the poor
that are cast out bring them to your
homes when you see people naked you see
the the
theme is repeated there so god is
telling us
what he wants us to do those are the
gifts he expects us to give
more so than expecting to receive gifts
i think that's why the bible says it's
better to give than to receive right
there's a blessing that comes along with
that
and um i i can remember many times
um my wife's family uh we actually would
would choose a family in the local town
that either unfortunate or you just knew
that they're
you know economically not at the same
level of everyone else
and we would all each go and pick out
gifts and then just randomly show up at
that person's house
knock on the door with bags of gifts and
give it to them
and they're just blown away now you do
something like that for somebody they're
gonna they're gonna ask
why are you doing this like who are you
what are you doing and and so
you know that's what i mean by this
opportunity you can
you can have a a um a christ-like
focus where people are going to be more
open
yeah i actually read a story about a
family who did something similar
they saved up their money all year for
christmas gifts
but they did not give gifts to each
other
they chose a project either an
organization
a family a non-profit they chose
something that they that was their
project for the year
and the christmas gift all their monies
went into getting
gifts for that particular project have
you guys ever seen those
magazines that come where you can buy
somebody a sheep or a
goat or something you've never seen is
that illegal oh yeah oh yeah
so um where where are these people that
you're buying the sheep in the vote for
generally in third world countries okay
so organizations that will go
there and if you provide a goat to
somebody
they can sell the milk and so you're
giving them a tool for that family to
actually go
and make money with it throughout the
year now
however that actually pans out
the reason i asked was when we were in
kenya at the end of 2018
that was one of the things they were
talking about how they were helping
certain families in the rural areas
by giving them goats goats are a big
thing in kenya
yeah big thing we saw just block the
road when you're driving and you just
have to sit and wait for them to
cross it's like giving a car to them
yeah i mean it's like that
large of a like whoa somebody just gave
me a goat
now i can eat you know for the next year
yeah and we don't think about that and
and some of these things are not very
expensive in terms of what you would
think
would be expensive you know like i don't
remember the prices but 50 bucks would
would
buy them an incredible gift that would
keep giving all year long even digging a
well is not expensive for
us but it's a life-saving thing for them
well let's see what the early christians
were doing history.com has an article
about the
history of christmas ma can you read
that for us
by holding christmas at the same time as
the traditional winter solstice
festivals
church leaders increased the chances
that christmas would be popularly
embraced
but gave up the ability to dictate how
it was celebrated
by the middle ages christianity had for
the most part replaced
pagan religion on christmas
believers attended church then
celebrated raucously in a drunken
carnival-like atmosphere similar to
today's
mardi gras isn't that crazy
well it's not so crazy where i grew up
that's exactly what happened
yeah we had in in my
island home for christmas time
we had the christmas masquerade yeah
and it came i think it it came down the
slaves decided that they were going
to bring with them some of the
african culture and they pulled from
different places different cultures
different aspects so what used to happen
people went to midnight mass and i mean
we weren't uh sunday worshipers but we
would go
our friends would invite us so we would
go to midnight mass it started at 10 and
it ended at midnight
hence the name right after that
most people were the adults
they started drinking and partying the
drunkenness that they're talking about
here that's what happened
and then during when the daytime came
there were these parades that went
through the different villages
and towns and the people dressed up
so the main character in the parade
was this guy dressed up in banana leaves
dried banana leaves
and he was on these tall stilts
um and he was called papa jab which
is daddy devil daddy interesting jab is
devils
because we speak a creole which is i
like broken french french it has its own
grammar and structure and then his
his wife was mary
and and he had all these little devils
called
tea jabs around they're like elf
yes and then they went through the
villages
there were a couple other characters in
in the band
but they went through the villages
frightening children so they would go
after the children make
faces because their faces were all
painted
like masks and stuff wow and we were so
scared we didn't
run back into the houses and that seemed
to have been the
object they were go they were actually
scaring the children because the myth
that they were following were we're
going to take
these children for to the devil oh wow
feed the devil with these children these
are the same people that had just been
to midnight
yes midnight right before they were in
church worshipping
i was hungry what was gonna be for
halloween i mean
oh well we didn't work we didn't
celebrate we don't celebrate halloween
yeah they had christmas instead so if
you look up
krampus k-r-a-m-p-u-s
it's a christmas celebration where
there's a big parade like you're saying
and
it's straight up like demons horns the
goat hoofs and they
walk around and they scare the children
no i've heard that a lot it's like a
scary santa that's my understanding
where was it
australia australia slovenia hungaria
czech a number of places central europe
eastern
culture has its own very its own
variation of that yeah
so like in the majority of the world
christmas is something scary
and it actually is pointing back to its
origin
because there is this demonic theme
running through it
through the activities i i think that
that
humans we we like to have these seasons
and things come around and things
change and it's like we have something
to anticipate for and
you know it's just kind of like part of
our our our insides like i can imagine
in jewish culture you know all of the
festivals that they had the festivals
the trumpets the you know festivals of
the of the
different things that they looked
forward to every year to come around
and see the devil knows exactly what
we're like
inside and he just leans on that and
says well they're naturally inclined to
be like this
so i'm just going to kind of bend this a
little bit and and push it and it's
really sad
that that you know he has to pervert
everything oh and and it just you know
muddles up what the real truth and
and things for us to look forward to but
no man can serve two masters
this is just confusion i have a question
uh what about in europe you know we talk
about in
here in america and some part in africa
they do that but
in actually it's in the caribbean i grew
up in a caribbean island okay
uh what about uh ireland what about
england how was the
celebrating you know christmas or the
birth of christ
so i don't know for sure but seeing as
the main religions in those places
stemmed from catholicism it's probably
similar
yeah yeah they all kind of have
different interesting um
sort of things like christmas like i
remember one of the girls that used to
work with us
from the netherlands and she would tell
us about how the netherlands have this
um character who dresses all in black
and it's like a week before christmas or
something and he
comes down i can't remember what it was
but it was something sort of like
semi-scary
and they did that same sort of thing but
in the end it's like it was scary but
then he gave gifts to everyone and it
was all better
yeah a guy named satan i mean santa
comes down your chimney gives you gifts
and watches you in your sleep
oh man well i grew up in mexico and
i didn't grow up as a catholic you know
perhaps a christian
and but the catholic
tradition down there uh they do you know
kind of need the
like 12 days before christmas
they sing they they you know come to a
future group and they sing and you know
carols and stuff like that
and they invite you over what are you
seeing like maybe like i don't know
like an hour sigh or 30 minutes and it's
you know feet you know it's kind of like
a uh when joseph and mary
go knock in the door and nobody open the
doors
so it's kind of like they're doing the
same thing with music with candles and
everything
and then they open the door and it has a
big party inside tambales
so it's like kind of like the tradition
you know when it's christmas uh
i remember you know like like santa
claus you know
the one guy over there i mean it's just
maybe in the in
the magazines you know stuff like that
but that's like somebody but now
i mean it's all over me it's all over
you know stuff like that but
as a christian i remember uh christmas
he was it was very special you know you
buy
they give you a nice very clothing
especially for christmas
you go to church and uh
they have a sermon you know something
very nice and the church is very
you know maybe the pastor talking about
christmas i mean the birth of christ and
stuff like that
but after that i mean we go i remember i
go home and
a nice dinner and
we use quality you know kind of like
hanging out and talking with the cousins
and stuff like that
but if you go visit with you your family
your friends
says not the same beliefs you know and
stuff like that i mean it was very
different
he was he was partying it was done until
like four in the morning you know
yeah i think we had something similar
yeah in
in my island um because the
the the masquerade was the cultural
thing yeah
but on a family basis families got
together
they had a special mail yeah and the
churchill
all the churches did caroling yeah
before either the day
the night before maybe a couple of
nights before they actually
the choirs and the groups who go and
sing in front of people's homes and just
carol they will go in front of the old
people's homes or those types of homes
and
sing and people come out to the windows
and it was a very
happy time so you had this this um
mixture this this evil depiction
in the cultural activity but when it
came to the homes it was more on
community and relationship people
visited friends and family members
ate with them drank special drinks that
just come at christmas time like sorrel
drink and
ginger beer and then the fruit cakes
yes the grape juice and the fruit cakes
and there were special
things that only came out at christmas
time onto the table
yeah i i kind of grew up with that kind
of a thing too
there were special things that my family
did just during christmas time and
i mean it was it was a time for family
and
uh my dad from an early on really kind
of taught us
to to use your talents and your gifts to
bless other people so
we would often make our own christmas
gifts and it was fun we would start you
know a
month or two before and think about you
know what would be special for each
person
and um i still to this day i i make
things and i like to give it to them
you know because most people can go out
and buy whatever they want and you know
it's like
for me it's just kind of a thing to
bless other people
and and i try to instill that into my
children as well as
is is you know this is a time of the
year that that
people are are generally open to
um you know more kindness or anything
like that and so to really kind of
keep that perspective and not get
wrapped up into the whole
you know commercialism of it to share
the gospel you know yeah that's true
so there are a lot of things that happen
during christmas both good
and bad and when celebrating people ask
a lot of questions like okay well what's
wrong with caroling what's wrong with
charity
church services what's wrong with giving
and receiving gifts
right or decorating our homes and
especially what's wrong with having a
specific day just to remember christ's
birth
well what's wrong is the origin it's the
biggest point
really no matter what is done the fact
that it's done in
such close alignment with something
that's not of god
is enough to make me want to separate
myself from it
and each person needs to make that
decision for themselves
there's a principle that we push really
hard on this channel it's that it's not
necessarily
the thing itself it's the motive behind
it right
and all of this started if you remember
because the church took something that
belonged to paganism
and made it their own so what's wrong
for me isn't really
the question that we should ask the
correct question
is why why are we doing these things for
example
i don't decorate my my house on
halloween
just for the sake of decorating it
because there's nothing wrong with
decorating my house right right
someone walking on the street they're
not gonna us wonder why i decorated my
house if it's
in a certain time in a certain context
they're going to assume oh yeah she's
celebrating just like the rest of the
nation right
so um the question really is
are we am i are you
comfortable with being grouped together
with everything else that is associated
with that particular thing right
i'll leave that there for you to think
about but with all this fuss
and debate about um what should or
shouldn't be done on whichever
particular day
i think there's one voice that we really
need to be paying attention to
how has jesus asked us to remember his
life
have you thought about that do any
scriptures come to mind
be there for like uh
making me an example there's a vital
verse like that right yeah
i just forget okay i'll try to first
we'll try to find it
but there's here's a common one do this
in remembrance of me what's the context
of that communion
that's right luke chapter 22 and
he asked us to do this to remember his
sacrifice for us and also to look
forward
to the day of his return so that's just
one example but throughout the bible
there's or throughout i should say the
gospels
um but the bible as well jesus makes
points throughout saying do this
specifically and do that in association
with me so as we balance things out how
much time are we spending on christ
and the things that he has instituted
and specifically asked us to do
versus secular things and man-made
because we should be following christ
right as the name implies
christians so chris
christmas is a holiday that isn't going
anywhere so
what is a good alternative and we kind
of talked about that you guys shared
your experiences about what things that
you did
in a christian home growing up how can
we acknowledge it but not necessarily
celebrate it and someone brought up this
is a good time to share the love of
christ because people
are just in that mindset do any other
things come to mind
um the other day it was two weeks ago
uh right across the street from my house
it's like this this rich couple
and they used to like open their house
every
every christmas and they they played
santa mrs claus and all that and they
had like a big slay or whatever
but this year i guess they changed it
because of covet or whatever but it was
really cool actually they their
driveways like this really long driveway
and um they had set these stations
that were the scenes of christ's birth
all up to his crucifixion
and there was we waited in an hour we
waited an hour just to get in line there
was just
cars everywhere and they give you a cd
to put in your car
and when you get to the first station
there's a guy he's talking and he's
narrating what you're seeing
and so the first scene was the angel
telling mary that she was
gonna be pregnant and and you actually
see it acted out it was a live nativity
and it was like ten different ten
different
scenes that were all acted out and you
were hearing it played out over the cd
player
i thought that was awesome yeah that was
a great way to
really share the gospel with somebody
that might not
they might have just said hey this is a
little christmas thing and then went
through it and just totally got exposed
to the gospel right there that's right
i think if you're looking for a way to
to either share a christ-like um
attribute or to involve yourself with
your community i mean
you know i know this debate is as old as
as i am
and i've heard uh it and and even at
certain times i've i've kind of like
pushed away on the whole christmas thing
and like i want nothing to do with it
but i think the people that i would like
to reach out to
and witness to and you know they may not
have those same kind of ideas and if you
just like dog
on it and you're like you know this is
not supposed to be whatever like this
i think we separate ourselves from the
opportunity that we could have had
and and i try to always put things like
how would christ actually
what would he be like if he came and
walked around in our place right now
was he walking around amongst his people
being like shouldn't do that
shouldn't do that i'll show you the
history on that you know what i mean
like i don't see jesus as being like
that
if you asked him he would tell you he
would say hey this is where this comes
from
and but i just don't see him as walking
into an environment and just sort of
hammering people for what they're doing
he was always looking for a way to to to
reach them
like the woman at the well he's reaching
her he didn't he didn't tell her what
she was doing wrong
first thing he waited until there was a
moment where she would have been
receptive of that
and i think sometimes we can push people
away
if we come you know out guns blazing and
this and that and we'll kill off an
opportunity
so for what you just shared that
experience of inviting people
into your home and your space i mean can
you imagine if
if you were a secular person and all of
a sudden it's like you get exposed to
like this nativity story and
who are these people that are so kind
and you know they let me in their house
and all of a sudden they give me gifts
and i'm walking out the
door with fruitcake you know like
what are you who are you and i think you
can open up that opportunity to share
christ
i remember going to a church once and
in a corner to the side to the
front on the right side there was a
christmas tree
and people actually were going up and
clipping money to the tree and at the
end
they took that money and they gave it to
the poor wow
that's beautiful i wish that we would
take more of an opportunity like this
time of the year it's not like you said
not going anywhere
and and i want to be very careful how i
say this because i don't want to confuse
people and say well we just need to like
you know jump on board and everybody's
celebrated or whatever
i think we need to respect people in in
if they feel like hey i want nothing to
do with this and you know i want to go
over here i think that's
that's that's great we need to allow
those little bits of space of
and not hammer them or even the other
side
but i wish that we would we'd use the
opportunity to really
train our kids and train ourselves to be
like others focused
this is a time to be super giving to
people this is a time to
to share the stories of christ and to
get together with family and to build
memories and things like that and i
think like
it would be great if we did that at some
other time of the year but it's not
always convenient
people work it's just more difficult so
this time that we get a chance to get
together
i just think we need to keep the right
focus absolutely
and to your point about jesus he didn't
some sometimes he didn't even have to
say anything
his example was his greatest witness
people would ask him questions because
hey why are you so different
and maybe as christians we should not be
so afraid of being different
it's okay to not go all out in terms of
decorations and gifts on christmas
that's right and allow people the space
to ask you questions
so in recent times christian christmas
has
actually been turned into xmas have you
guys heard people say that merry xmas
well x stands for the unknown
right right and it's like an opportunity
so now religious and non-religious
people can come together and celebrate
the unknown right so in response to that
some have started saying let's put
christ back in christmas
you've heard that they're trying to x
out christ out of christmas right
well i would go further and say let's
put christ back in
christian yeah and it should be a
lifestyle thing
you shouldn't just act a certain way or
just share christ during christmas
because that's the right thing to do
it should be your lifestyle throughout
the year so
schedule some time maybe to have a bible
study before dinner
or after dinner before the basketball
game
or go out and share some food and maybe
you'll decide to skip the ball game all
together
you know um but i would say take
opportunity to share christ outside of
that
one hour church service you know some
people only show up to church
that time of year that time in easter
right
and even like to your point about the
person that created the nativity scene
there are people who
how do i say this
sometimes people think they know the
stories in the bible
but it they're missing the little
details that lead to
misunderstanding and misconceptions
about the story so even something as
building the nativity scene people might
say oh everyone is doing that but are
they doing it correctly
or any scene really or christmas plays
or whatever the case
what has been added that's not
necessarily biblical and what can
be presented that can open up a bible
study to literally any other topic that
the bible talks about
here's something um we live in in
chattanooga and there is a church
um in our area that during the easter
time they do
a huge um creation no
during the easter time they do a huge
creation of of the story of christ
and his crucifixion and i can't remember
how many thousands it's
i think it's in the tens of thousands of
people that go through this
thing and you know i know a lot of
people
will say oh that's that's catholic and
that's you know this and that and
they'll sort of dog on that
but it was designed to bring the
community around
this christian school and then
at the very end of it where you end up
with jesus being resurrected
there's a call that's made there if you
would like to know more
we will have bible studies with you fill
out this card leave it here like this
and they have the community who
i mean you see the people there they're
in there with earrings and tattoos
but i mean just like people that you
wouldn't immediately look at and be like
that's a christian
and they're sitting there watching
christ be resurrected
and so there's i think there's two ways
to look at that
somebody may look at that and be like
well that's just easter and we're just
blending this with
this and that or this is a church that's
using the opportunity to
share christ with somebody and and open
up the door so
i i would hope that we would walk away
from from
um some of these things not getting you
know
uh the wrong idea about it but like you
said it's just
it just has to be um the right focus
that's right use it as a time to educate
people around you
about the love of christ and that may be
what jesus meant when he said to worship
him
in spirit and in truth not so much by
the letter
of the law yeah so the pharisees
it was look in jesus that
jesus disciple was eating things on the
sabbath
and he said why do you do that you're
not supposed to do that you know stuff
like that
but jesus said hey you can do good
i mean if you have your kids asking for
food you don't want to give them you
know because it's a sabbath day
so why you told me that but and the
other religious thing is like hey
you're not supposed to do that boy you
know what i'm saying so it's kind of
like
like chris i mean you don't gonna be
open to tell about
the jesus story yeah someday he was born
jesus the savior so you're gonna be just
closing your thing
you bring up you bring up a really good
point there's there's two ways to share
truth
and i've learned this by um i i follow
the sabbath
right and when i when i was working in
television um
they the guys that i worked for the
production company they worked for were
all jewish
and so when i came to them and said i
need
i need sabbath off and it starts on
friday night they immediately knew what
i was talking about
and then they were just like oh really
because we've seen you party on the
weekends you know and i was just like
you just want to go and hang out with
your friends and i said no
i need friday night to sabbath off and
they actually allowed me to have it
and so i would share with people on the
productions about the sabbath but i was
very like
it's the sabbath you need to be you know
right and i was just kind of beating
people over the head
with this truth now i'm sharing truth
was it wrong for me to to share it
no but the approach that i came at was
wrong
and the way that i was basically beating
people with this piece of truth
made it why would they even want to keep
the sabbath if i'm coming at them like
that
and i've learned how to like there's a
way to share the truth
right so the pharisees weren't
necessarily like
a lot of those those laws that they were
following to the letter of the law
remember um before jesus came down to
earth he's the one that spoke
on mount sinai and gave moses a lot of
these things they were following the
things that that very
being gave them to follow but the way
that they were doing it was just this
unchrist-like spirit you you can't eat
this on
on the sabbath and this and that right
and so i want i bring that story up
because you bring up a really good point
i i honestly believe that there is a a
pagan origin to christmas there is
that's that's a fact and um you can run
around
and beat people over the head with that
piece of truth
and then all of a sudden you build up
this wall does that make sense
and so it's like kind of the same way
that the pharisees approached jesus
it's like they're telling you something
that's true but it's the way that they
went about
it and so if people are like well
whatever you know like
you have this opinion of christmas now
i'm gonna unsubscribe from your channel
and not listen to you
that would not be the most best way to
do it so here is my advice
with anything that's truth if somebody
does something that that you believe is
wrong or contrary
a really great approach to them and say
hey i have this
this um this this study that i was
looking into the origins of
of christmas would you be interested in
looking at it
that's a beautiful way to say i'm giving
you the opportunity to understand
something about this
if you sit there and say i'm going to
bombard you smack you over the head and
if you don't get this then i just want
don't even want to talk to you that's
not that's not the way to approach it
so i think with anything when we share
truth
we should really have a christ-like
approach even
in the way that we do it so if we're if
we're sharing with people about you know
christmas or even some of the origins of
christmas
if we do it in in a kind nice manner and
allow people to open themselves up to
that piece of information
i think that's a better approach and in
talking about being christ-like here's
some examples of how we can be
christ-like
like putting james 1 27 to use isaiah 58
that entire chapter beautiful chapter
matthew 25 verses 35 through 36
and philippians 4 verse 8. all of these
if we put them into practice throughout
the year
not just during the holiday time can
really impact change not just in our
lives but those around us
we actually have a shirt about that in
james
says pure religion is caring for the
orphans and widows
and refusing to let the world corrupt
you
that's uh that's what pure religion is
that's right
so again during christmas who
or what are we paying homage to
and are we doing it in a way that is
acceptable
to that person and if not
maybe we should reconsider the practice
altogether so i guess
on christmas if we are like if we don't
believe in celebrating christmas it
doesn't mean we have to close our door
but we have to use christmas or that day
as an opportunity to open our doors
since people
are more likely to be open to receive
the
the truth about the gospel
and i guess we also need to have a right
motive our motive is to
you know to share instead of to show
them that they're wrong
it's to show them the truth i mean
because i guess there's a difference to
show that you are wrong and to show
what is truth my kids um we had a male
lady that was
um delivering mail in our in our
subdivision and um
it was really amazing this lady had a
near photographic memory she met my kids
once
didn't see my kids for six months and
then one day i saw her delivering mail
and she said how's carly and mason your
kids
and i was just like do they talk to you
like
i was kind of shocked by that and she
she told me
she said no you know i just remember
everybody's name and i was like well
you're in the right business right
my kids during one christmas wrote her a
note left it in the mailbox
drew a little picture on it and just
said you know merry christmas and she
was
incredibly touched by that and so you
know during that time
where people like your mail lady are
probably stressed out to the max i mean
i'm still waiting for packages around
this time of the year that's taken two
months to get to me
and and you know it's your opportunity
to just bless somebody else
and to you know just wish them a a
beautiful day or
or leave a little gift in your mailbox
for them or something like that
would be nice so can we say merry
christmas how can we say holidays
i mean let the holy spirit guide you
[Laughter]
another another thing we can do is
find find a place where or
an organization that reaches out to the
less fortunate
there are places i know in new york
there are places where
the homeless are fed and they know
to go to that place for food on
christmas and thanksgiving
so that's one of the ways we can we can
actually go
and give our time donate our time
and serving those people who don't have
what we usually have
that's right you kind of mentioned a
similar thing but
one year we got these like plastic
boxes kind of like a giant lunchbox or
something
and then we got like four of them and we
did two for boys and two for girls and
we just
you know a lot of like dollar tree
little toys and stuff it doesn't
take a lot of money i think to we might
have spent 50 bucks on the whole thing
you know but
each kid got you know pencils and
little toys and stuff but there was a
there was a gospel
track in each one of those and we just
we looked for people that looked needy i
remember we were
getting our tire changed and some
somebody else was getting their tire
changed the car was beat up their
clothes weren't
the greatest and and i was just like hey
lily there's a kid over there
aren't we and so she went over there we
said uh
we went to the adult first we said do
you mind if we
give your kid a gift or whatever and
they're like oh yeah sure thank you you
know
and it was just like you said like such
a people are like
why are you doing this why are you
giving me something and i don't know
whatever happened you know that they had
that
gospel track in there and it might have
helped them it might have changed their
life who knows
there's a lot of little tracks that
people have i keep them in my car
and and you know they just are on
different biblical topics or or
something
and it's really easy to just share a
piece of
literature with somebody so i think at
this time of the year at least in my
experience
um people are more receptive to take
that at this time of the year than they
sometimes would at other times of the
year so yeah if you
put together something like that throw a
little piece in there that would that
would
explain to someone or kind of connect
the dots for someone
why are you doing this like what are you
what are you why are you giving me this
stuff and you don't even know me
well it's because we believe in in
christ you know
it's beautiful thank you guys for
helping me with this topic and thank you
all for watching please prayerfully
consider what we discussed here today
and if you liked the video
please hit the like button and subscribe
and leave in the comments section
which holiday is your favorite mine is
international pancake day
when is that what is that every every
week in my house
we'll see you guys next week on led live
[Music]
you